la russie et les etats unis ont vraiment
besoin de coopérer a déclaré l'envoyé
spécial des etats-unis pour le climat
john kerry en visite à moscou pour
plusieurs jours et la rencontre est
aujourd'hui le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov
je vous propose d'écouter évidemment il
y à certaines divergences dans les
relations entre nos pays mais nous
étions ravis que le président poutine
aient pris part au sommet au sommet
virtuel qui a eu lieu en avril
nous recherchons des éléments rationnels
et prévisible dans nos relations
la clé c'est d'être capable de traiter
de la question des changements
climatiques à part chez vous c'est
extrêmement important
c'est essentiel que nous avons vraiment
besoin de coopérer question ne fait pas
sens entre 2020 et 2030
nous ne pourrons pas limiter la hausse
des températures à 1,5 degré est arrivé
à zéro émission
les enjeux ne peuvent pas être plus
élevé je crois quant au chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
il a déclaré que la russie attaché une
grande importance aux problèmes liés au
changement climatique dans le monde et
qu'elle continuerait à coopérer
activement sur ces questions et coûter
cher monsieur le représentant spécial du
président cher john chers collègues nous
estimons que votre visite à moscou et
très opportune la russie attache une
grande importance aux problèmes liés au
changement climatique dans le monde et
continuera à coopérer activement sur les
questions climatiques dans le cadre des
plateformes internationales en premier
lieu avec les signataires de la
convention cadre des nations unies sur
les changements climatiques et
conformément à l'accord de paris nous
contribuerons à la recherche de
solutions collectives aux problèmes qui
se posent dans ce domaine en partant de
nos conditions nationales et de nos
objectifs de développement socio
économique
dans ce contexte dans le cadre de ce
travail nous comptons sur une
coopération étroite avec les états unis
notamment dans le cadre des négociations
entre les membres de la convention-cadre
afin d'assurer le succès de leur réunion
à glasgow cet automne
je considère également votre visite
comme un signal important et positif du
point de vue du développement de nos
relations bilatérales de l'élimination
des tensions au sein de celle-ci et de
la mise en place d'un travail
professionnel et de fonds dans les
domaines où nous pouvons trouver des
dénominateurs communs
ce n'est pas la première fois que john
kerry et sergey lavrov se voient pour
discuter de la problématique du
réchauffement climatique la dernière
rencontre lavrov kerry a eu lieu à new
delhi en avril lors de la visite de
travail du chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov en inde
ensuite le 1er juillet ils ont eu un
entretien téléphonique consacrée à la
coopération russo américaine en matière
du climat c'est lors de cet échange que
les diplomates se sont mis d'accord de
poursuivre des contacts réguliers dans
l'esprit du sommet poutine baden qui a
eu lieu le 16 juin à genève